[Musique]
bonsoir martin mec colis merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
vient de le constater on a le sentiment
que ceux des confinement autour de
l'euro ça devient véritablement une
question quasi politique monsieur
hancock qui a été missionné en tant que
me sers de la santé était une personne
très prudente été très prudent dans son
approche du déconfinement mais le
nouveau secrétaire de la santé ministre
de la santé
sajid j'habite c'est bien plus rapide
pense beaucoup plus à l'économie
et il l affirme donc que le confinement
et les restrictions prendront fin le 19
juillet c'est ce que la plupart des gens
veulent entendre les bien sûr il faut
attendre car aujourd'hui nous avons eu
25 mille nouveaux cas au rail et le neuf
et ce n'est pas la fin de l'épidémie au
royaume uni vous vous faites référence à
ce ministre de la santé qui a dû
démissionner ce week-end après cette
vidéo compromettante 1 il embrassait une
femme qui n'était pas la sienne voilà
hasard ou coïncidence
cette vidéo qui a été publié ça tombait
bien qu'il soit poussé vers la sortie en
ce moment justement pour faire primer
l'économie alors de l'euro un balayage
et tous les gars de pékin la ministre
c'est très mauvais pour le gouvernement
car le premier ministre avait dit l'
affaire est close matin coque restera
ministre de la santé
et puis bien sûr matin coq a lui-même
décidé de démissionner et cela a mis le
gouvernement en difficulté
le point clé de cette démission
ce sont les images enregistrées par une
caméra placée dans son propre bureau qui
a enregistré une embrassade entre lui et
son assistant
donc c'est devenu un sujet politique car
cela pourrait également devenir un
problème de sécurité
ces caméras à circulent fermé aurait pu
capter des images de documents sur son
bureau
ces documents auraient pu contenir des
informations très importantes notamment
en matière de sécurité
je nous ne savons donc pas pour le
moment si l'on va étudier le sujet si
les services de sécurité vont prendre
affaires en main pour le moment ils
essayent de minimiser la situation
il espère que les images captées par ces
caméras
ne mettront pas le gouvernement en
difficulté la caméra a été supprimée par
le nouveau ministre de la santé et elle
c'est vraiment une situation très
embarrassante pour le gouvernement et au
pire moment bien sûr les coulisses de me
reprend au royaume uni et nous avons
besoin de quelqu'un d'expérimenté vous
pouvoir le nouveau ministre de la santé
va trouver son emploi difficile mais
comme je les dis il se prend que plus
d'économies que de confinement donc il
maintient cette date du 19 juillet pour
la faim tue un confinement et au milieu
donc le rôle mais ce qui inquiète de
l'assouplissement autour de certains
matches de l'euro on rappelle quand même
qu'on a pris officiellement aujourd'hui
près de 300 supporters étaient testés
positifs de retour en finlande après
avoir assisté à l'euro l'uefa qui met un
petit peu la pression quand même que
peut être l'attitude de londres des
autorités britanniques c'est très
cornélien l'économie ou ou la santé
ça se pose clairement le groupe chris
viehbacher
c'est une question très intéressante car
f1 a dit que la finale pour être
transférée à budapest en hongrie pour
que et dans ce stade de pushkar à
budapest
on peut accueillir autant de fans que
c'est possible mais je vous rappeler ce
n'est pas le cas et de nombreuses
personnes vont se rendre à londres pour
la finale le fêter on n'a pas demandé à
ses représentants de l'uefa de se
soumettre à une quarantaine
le gouvernement britannique doit acter
signer décider si la finale à wembley
peut prendre place ce qui effectivement
a été un enjeu économique majeur
si du point de vue salutaire ils doivent
considérer que me risque est trop élevé
et que cette finale pourrait introduire
des personnes contaminées au royaume uni
et qu'il faudrait donc transférer cette
finale à budapest mais la finale prendra
place je crois le 31 juillet nous avons
encore beaucoup de temps il faut donc
attendre et voir
car shalik jarry le nouveau ministre de
la santé a déclaré que toutes les
restrictions seraient levés le 19
juillet c'est dans c'est donc toujours
avant la finale il faut voir ce qui va
arriver
les supporteurs britanniques adoré avoir
une finale à londres
ils ont de grands espoirs et espère
également que l'équipe d'angleterre sera
en finale mais cela serait peut-être
trop dangereux et donc il faut attendre
car comme je voulais dit il y a eu
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
nouveaux cas de coronavirus aujourd'hui
à londres au royaume uni donc pour le
gouvernement c'est un choix
véritablement quand des liens beaucoup
de personnes dirais que c'est trop
dangereux que l'argent n'est pas
important par rapport à la santé de la
population
du point de vue des affaires du point de
vue des médias cependant il faudrait que
la finale prennent place à londres car
cela générait d'énormes sommes d'argent
et cela rendrait londres très populaire
merci beaucoup martine may colis
analyses politiques d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france soir